All right, folks,
almost revving it up here.
I heard there are a couple of more talks
after me, but let's
talk about reliability.
Reliability is hard and it's rare.
What we do, what I do is I'm
Hannes Lenke.
I'm CEO and co-founder of
Checkline, and we help you to
detect, communicate, and resolve
issues fast.
I'm on a mission
to help your engineers
to own reliability
from pull request to postmortem.
Software,
take a step back a decade ago,
software was built.
Yearly,
shipped quarterly,
then monthly,
weekly,
daily,
and now we're almost there
where agents can
build the software, ship faster,
almost instantly.
That's cool.
On the other side,
Reliability is eroding.
Reliability is still in 2013.
And we gotta think about how
to bring that in the into the
modern age.
Why is that though?
Yesterday,
Applications were very simple, right?
You had one single team,
maybe 123 dependencies,
a database.
And when you
uh released something and something went
wrong,
then you do exactly.
What kind of service was responsible for it?
That was yesterday.
Now today,
Applications are much more complex,
right? They
have dependencies, a renewed dependency
that you're introducing.
Introduces
potential. Failure
risks to your reliability
and I'm, I'm not saying that's bad to
be honest,
you know, all these integrations if it's off
if it's
uh payment providers, databases,
etc.
they allowed us to ship fast and they're
still allowing us to ship fast because we don't need
to build everything
right? But
everything is kind of connected to each other.
And
Reliability is left behind.
Now,
the answer was for years.
More people,
more processes,
more tech.
You tested your application,
you monitor your application.
And
we had, you know, different teams
doing that, right, so there was a QA team doing
these tests, developers building the
application and
operations monitoring.
Being responsible for production.
The funny thing though is.
You know,
both teams,
both processes
try to answer a very similar,
if not the same question.
Does your application work from an end user
perspective?
It's all about validating that
your boat works on staging.
Validating that it still works on
production
after a while,
catching failures
before your users actually
see these failures on staging
and catch failures later on
because you know, one of the services that
you depend on
might have an issue or someone
might change an API end point, etc.
Want to verify your uh integrations.
And look at performance over time, right, a
certain performance over time.
These are a lot of things that you.
That you need to do
That we're
used to doing.
Whose automated tasks.
During
uh CICD.
And later on,
on production, we use manual testing,
etc.
Of course we try to automate as much as
possible. You
know, throughout
all of our customers that we have, we have
1300 paying customers
across the world.
There's three principles that we are seeing
that the high performing teams are
pretty much adopting.
One is predictability,
really being able to predict how your
app works.
When you release it to production
and before you release it to production,
is accountability,
really knowing
what changed.
Who changed it,
why,
when, and really knowing
if a problem
occurs.
Where it comes from,
and then that feeds into resiliency,
you wanna be able
to really build a resilient
application and worst case,
roll your application back
fast so that your users are not
affected.
So what Jackie does is
we unify
testing and monitoring
in one workflow.
Your playwright tests, your API
tests, your uptime checks,
your alerts, status pages,
they all follow one workflow. They
follow a workflow
that is made
for a software development life cycle.
All version controlled
and it's built for speed.
So how do we do this? How do our
customers do this?
They build these
checks,
tests.
In playwright for UI automation.
JavaScript TypeScript
for API testing.
Um,
And then uptime monitors, all
as code.
And then they deploy them over
to our platform and we run them
continuously across the world
to let you know.
About issues before you use or face them.
This was our mantra for, for the
last decade, right? You build it, you
run it, you own it.
This is a mantra of the past.
I don't think it keeps up until today.
Who's you in this case?
Who is it?
You know, everyone who touches
the user experience of a
customer.
Is you in my mind
and touching the user experience of customer
nowadays
is obviously SIE uh SIE,
uh,
you know, someone who's responsible pretty much for the
code, a developer, an engineer.
And the reality though is
It's now augmented with agents,
it's cloud code and all the other tools. Who
are you use is using today,
agents
to develop code?
All right. Some of
you Tomorrow,
I believe.
Agents will be capable enough
to build even more code,
in the end ship code,
monitor code,
so it will become.
You build it,
you test it,
you monitor it.
You're on it.
That's what Jackie's made for.
We give you tests.
That you can promote to monitors.
You can define alerts.
Status pages,
so really detect issues,
communicate them,
and in the end you get the assets that
you need to resolve issues fast.
To do one thing,
it's pretty much integrating
your monitoring stack
into the CICE stack.
So your CICDs pipeline
that you have today, maybe with end
to end to end tests speaks the same
language as your reliability pipeline.
You speak in your organization
the same language.
All teams use the same frameworks,
use the tests that are already built during,
uh, during the software development.
For monitoring,
they look at the same assets when something
fails,
really know
if something goes wrong.
That speeds you up.
Also enables you to speak pretty much
uh
that language from your local
development
towards production.
All right. That
was my talk
If you want to talk about how to bring
reliability and monitoring
into the modern age, then
visit us at our booth. It's 1856.
It's over there.
Thank you.